&gt;&gt; These equations are not in slope-intercept form so it would be pretty tough
to use graphing. We'd have to do a lot of rearranging and then plot points. If
we were graphing, we could have also made tables, but that could take a lot of
work, too. So, I'm going to take out graphing. If we want to use substitution,
we need one of the equations solved for one variable. This one is almost solved
for x. All I would need to do would be to subtract 3 from both sides. Then, I
could perform substitution. So, x could equal 2y minus 3 and now, I'd be ready
to substitute this in to my first equation for x. That's a pretty great choice.
If you were leaning towards elimination, you might have thought to multiply the
second equation by negative 5. If we distribute the negative 5, we would get
negative 15 minus 5x minus 10y. Now, we could add these equations together. I
would want to switch the places of these two terms so that way I could add my x
terms together more easily. Now, I'm actually ready to do elimination. And I
would get negative 4y minus 15 equals negative 10y plus 9. Notice I can't
combine these, because their not like terms. This has a y and this doesn't. This
also has a y and this doesn't. This isn't so great with elimination. I'm having
to do a lot of steps, and I'm having to reorder a lot of terms. So, that's why I
think substitution is the best here.